everyone was screaming like Kelly Kelly
knows like if you only knew is happening
behind this curtain not pretty it's been
17 years since I was on Idol so maybe
there's some secrets that might happen I
don't know or maybe I've said everything
I don't know either I have no filter
flood sees together shall we never have
I ever gone on a date with one of my
fellow contestants why yes I did but not
when people thought we were dating Jess
and I actually didn't date on the show
and we didn't date Wilde filming from
Justin Kelly we dated like a little bit
in between but it was more because we
were like shoved together like you know
cuz we we were the top two that season
and we were doing all this press
together and and it was a big huge
experience for two kids that had no idea
that all was gonna happen so but yeah
he's my buddy he just did the show a
just to the Kelly Clarkson show and he's
doing really well but we did it for a
second
yes never have I ever been recognized in
public and said it wasn't me here's the
thing I tell people like when they're
like are you Kelly Clarkson but this has
happened quite a bit are you Kelly
Clarkson like oh yeah no you're not I am
I'm her and no you're not no I'm not I'm
not her you are her aren't you I am her
I just we've been over this and they
don't believe me and then they do
believe me and then it happens all the
time it's super fun and it's usually
pretty flattering because usually I have
no hair and makeup on if nothing like
Target or something I get it it looks
different move past this never have I
ever regretted a song choice whoa there
are some big money moves to be made
upstairs right now well here's the thing
that's not me if you were that there's
definitely a chair being moved and it
did not exit this body it's like that's
not fair
but anyway I forgot the question never
remember what
oh I wouldn't have regretted it had I
not had laryngitis I had never had
laryngitis before and that's saying a
lot because I grew up seeing opera and
musicals and then like a lot I was
always involved in a lot things never
change right I had to sing a Celine Dion
song called I surrender normally I can
sing I surrender and it's fine but when
you have laryngitis
well you sound like a dying cow it's
just a cruel joke really that the
universe played on me but that's okay
I think I got pity votes that week
laughing people back cuz they definitely
didn't vote for how great it was cuz it
wasn't never have I ever had a wardrobe
malfunction on Idol I didn't have a
wardrobe malfunction I actually wasn't
closed but I'd never worn fake eyelashes
before so they put eyelashes on me it
was my first time that anybody ever
actually saw me on the show and it was
the lives it was the top ten and I was
seeing respect I think and the lash came
off and it was like dangling kind of him
eyes so it looked like I was winking in
America maybe that's how I got the votes
but I was like oh me as me it was just I
was just winking the whole time it
looked like this and maybe that's how I
got votes you know America thought I was
winking at them worked didn't it
never have I ever sobbed during a
rehearsal I don't think I ever
shockingly enough I don't think I saw
during a rehearsal I feel like I
definitely solved when Christina
Christian couldn't make the show it was
actually live though she got sick and
had to be rushed to the hospital and she
wasn't there and then she ended up
getting let go that night from the show
something we were all even more sad
about that cuz that really sucked and we
were like kids at camp so we were really
sad for her but I don't know if I ever
cried in rehearsal which is shocking I
know
everyone's going she probably grinders
oh never have I ever had something I
interfere with my performance I don't
remember that happening on Idol no
definitely happened asked her one time
in Germany and this last tour was pretty
great everyone was screaming like Kelly
Kelly knows like if you only knew is
happening behind this curtain not pretty
food poisoning is no bueno but the show
must go on so I did and you just exit
the stage and then you come back on and
you're like I'm so sorry I had to
compete and then you're like it was
nothing
definitely not a number one scenario it
was yeah but you're on tour and you get
food poisoning catering doesn't always
work out never have I ever gotten in a
fight with another contestant no that's
not my vibe I'm just like if I don't
like some why I just don't talk to them
so if I don't talk to you you know I
don't like you or no way doesn't like
everyone you know we're all different I
generally do like most people though I'm
like kind of annoying like that like I
can find like a redeeming factor
whatever I will say there were fights on
American Idol behind the scenes there
was a bit of drama but an a my drama
size filling that teeth never have I
ever voted for myself
I don't think oh yes I have I have voted
for myself not on Idol I know this is
the American Idol audition but American
Idol made this moment happen I was
nominated for Grammy it's not definitely
devoted for myself it's like I don't
know I
wanted to cuz I worked hard for those
just like everybody else did so I I
definitely did vote for myself a couple
times for that but never on Idol I never
called in or anything we couldn't call
and we were so busy there was no time to
use a phone never have I ever cried from
something Simon said never because
here's the thing about that little
relationship he was never mean to me
that's awesome right you're thinking oh
for you but here's the thing so every
week everyone was like it's your turn
it's gonna happen and every week I was
like he's gonna dig into something and
it's gonna be so me and every year it
was all or every week it was almost
worse I was expecting it because it
hadn't been my turn yet and then every
time he's nice which freaks you out more
a little bit but it turns out he's just
nice to me and then and he's supportive
so yay I impressed the Brit never have I
ever asked Paula Abdul for her phone
number no I have not I am NOT a person
who generally asks for anyone's number
because I just I don't know I feel like
if they want me to have the number
they'll give it to me and if not then
like which summons to happen but I would
take Paula bill I would hang with all
that doll she's cool super sweet exactly
what you see on TV never if I ever said
it's an over me dog I'm not as cool as
Randy Jackson I think we're all aware
and I think it's it's out there I don't
ever use if I'm using the word dog it's
usually referring to the actual animal
I'm referring to
alright y'all this has been Kelly
Clarkson never have I ever
I don't have too many like things that
were maybe a surprise because I say
everything but I do love games so I hope
you enjoyed it if you didn't whatever
you just wasted all that time I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this